some new information on the Muslim
Brotherhood a group you've been hearing
a lot about a key opposition group
protesting right now in Egypt the
Brotherhood preaches political reform
but quote only to the extent Allowed by
the laws of Islam National correspondent
Katherine harage has been looking into
the background of the Brotherhood she
joins us with more what do you find out
Katherine well thank you John if you're
really going to simplify things there
are two factions within the Brotherhood
the doves and the Hawks and both got
their start in Egypt in 1928 when the
Muslim Brotherhood was founded the goal
of the Brotherhood at that time which
has not really changed is to build
Islamic societies from the ground up to
adhere to Sharia also known as Islamic
law that said the Muslim Brotherhood is
not on the state Department's list of
recognized terrorist organizations
though critics including a well-known
group Jihad watch says the Brotherhood
is extremely active in the
US according to a captured internal
document that was released by
prosecutors during the holy land
Foundation Hamas Terror funding case uh
in 2007 the Brotherhood in its own words
is dedicated in the United States to
eliminating and destroying Western
Civilization from within and sabotaging
its miserable house supporters of the
Brotherhood say these links that were
alleged during the Holy Land Foundation
case are unproven John so some of the
biggest names in terrorism really got
their started the Brotherhood right well
that's correct based on our research
Hamas is believed to be an offshoot of
the Palestinian Muslim Brotherhood jamat
al- islamia is a terrorist organization
in Indonesia and Al-Qaeda of course
through its number two am Al zawahiri
who was a member of the Brotherhood in
Egypt itself this is another interesting
example according to us interrogators
the self-described architect of 911 khi
shik Muhammad was drawn to Violent Jihad
he told them after joining the
Brotherhood in Kuwait when he was just
16 years old that picture there is from
uh his detention at guantan Mo Bay and
college shik Muhammad also said that he
attended the brotherhood's desert youth
training camps now that's important
because leading analysts say that the
Brotherhood is really like a stepping
stone to a more radical way of thinking
so in the case of klege shik Muhammad he
joined the Brotherhood as a teenager and
then went on to become a planner of 911
within Al-Qaeda itself John Katherine
harage in Washington keep us updated on
all of these iterations thanks you're
welcome